liberal teachers unions added again
eyeballing a return to remote learning
during the omicron surge members of the
chicago teachers union threatening to
strike if their demands aren't met and
other groups across the country testing
the waters for their own departures from
the classroom but once again the science
isn't on their side the arguments have
gone so far off the rails that even
people like dr fauci are saying school
should stay open
we've done the balance so many times
over the last year
about the deleterious effects of keeping
children out of in in physical presence
in the school
and it's very clear
that there are some really serious
effects about that it's safe enough to
get those kids back to school there's a
level of urgency that we shouldn't uh
lose around making sure that our
children learn in person
the impact of hybrid learning the impact
of remote learning is very real
all right judge the chicago school
districts have received 3 billion
with the b
from the taxpayers since this pandemic
began they can put in ventilation they
can put in the little hand sanitizing
stations they could build a plastic
igloo around each individual teacher's
desk to prevent this thing but they
still don't want to go into the
classroom what more do they want why
would they do any of that stuff if they
can strike and they can call it i think
they they call it a remote work action
and not a strike which is illegal
um by saying look we're not going back
to work unless it's safe so you've got
the the teachers unions now at odds with
the administration now remember
it was the administration's or so it
seemed the cdc taking information from
randy weingarten
and the uft united federation of
teachers now all of a sudden there's
this break where the teachers are like
we want to make sure all these kids are
are tested and are tested negative well
we just went through this in the a block
you can't get enough tests to test the
kids to begin with and now you want to
create this impossible hurdle so that
you don't have to go back to work this
is what's at odds now the administration
is facing 2022. they know the america
the the moms in america have had it they
saw it in virginia and now all this
nonsense where even the washington post
is coming out and saying it's really
time to kind of weather through this uh
severe illness is really uncommon among
children and all you teachers are
vaccinated so get back to work you've
been paid enough
all right so dana the judge said the
politicians are at a crossroads they're
going to have to either side with the
teachers unions or they side with the
students and their parents
what are they going to do well i
wouldn't be surprised to find out that
michael cardona the education secretary
was speaking in his personal capacity
and not as a secretary of education
however i do think that the reality has
all caught up with them i think many of
you probably saw over the past week
cheryl atkinson at cbs pointed out just
how horrible the lockdowns have been for
youth
and
it was
everybody nodded they all get it they
all know that this is happening more and
more research is going to come out that
shows that this was so harmful to them
from suicide rates to plunging test
scores the inability for them to get
back on track and you know the teachers
complain that there are behavioral
problems in the classroom oh really you
think so yeah because you kept them out
of school for a year and a half and just
recently there was a big article in the
new york times that really puffed up
randy weingarten and said that she as
the head of the teachers union was very
much trying to keep kids in school but
then
as the judge pointed out we have the
actual emails from the cdc and the
school districts that then went to the
white house it basically said that the
teachers wanted to keep schools closed
so i think all that is
something that's going to lead into this
question of who do you side with the
parents if you want to win the election
or the teachers unions if you want to
get political donations what do you
think the real reason is greg that
some teachers don't want to return to
the classroom
because there is no incentive for them
to return
joe biden said today said capitalism
without competition is exploitation he
was talking about the meat industry
i would reckon that that probably could
be applied to education one of these
days
uh
this is truly a teachable moment
literally here's the the area that you
could say arguably suffers the most
which is education is the one that
combats intensely any outside influence
that smacks of competition you know
imagine if any industry dealing with
children was like this you know uh they
can't offer an alternative child seat
you know they only make one car seat and
it sucks right but you got to buy it and
by the way we're not going to be in the
car with you okay good luck you know
that's what it's like they were making
one product and because there's no
competition there's no there's no push
for school choice uh they can make that
product as bad as they want it to be
they don't have to go so this pandemic
the teachable moment finally we have one
shows that you know you need school
choice affordable school choice or
you're going to end up in a bizarre
hostage situation you know where your
kids are basically held captive by
people who don't want to work
harold last word
this strike or whatever it is to be
called should be avoided at all costs i
think you've laid out all of us have
laid out
in clear ways the social mental
emotional and educational
impact negative impact this has had on
kids i do think
some of the demands that the teachers
are making around the mask
i think even many of our public health
experts as you noted dr fauci dr redfell
and others who all agree that kids
should be back in school i think that we
should have some uh consistency in
in the mask and that they shouldn't be
cloth mask but i would encourage mayor
lightfoot and others uh one of the
things that's best for kids put aside
electoral politics for one moment is to
find ways to get teachers and students
back in school and for us to be
competitive against china we have to
continue to educate our kids and a
minimum help them catch up from the year
they missed last year and being outside
of the classroom certainly does not aid
us and enabled us to do that it sure
doesn't